all right
we are live here we go
so i hope everybody is doing well
as i'm looking in the chat i see uh neil
degrade
dirt poor robin saying no masks in the
chat please
no mess in the chat
all right it's good it's good to be with
everybody
um i hope you're all doing well in this
strange times and this strange
uh confinement mode as we kind of
feel like uh the confinement
hopefully is ending
i'm seeing around me people just
starting to live their lives again
you know seeing stores open
seeing restaurants open and kind of put
tables outside you know and
everybody kind of pushing the limit a
little bit
so i hope everybody's doing okay and if
not
you know at least we have this weird
online space that we can kind of connect
with people
and uh and talk about how crazy these
times are
uh i thought i knew 2020 was going to be
crazy but
i really i didn't think it was going to
be this crazy so
so here we go guys uh a few a few little
news items
as you know on my website now we are
posting
articles we have several people writing
articles on symbolism on different
strains different aspects of symbolism
it's been really great people have been
stepping up the articles are wonderful
um i just just was it today i think it
was
yesterday yesterday uh nicholas kotar
who's been on my
channel posted an amazing little article
about fairy tales
and and the situation right now and the
the clampdown
um and vaccine so i think he's it's
called something like
you know why fairy tales might be better
than vaccines
so check that out and check out the
other articles that are there as well
people have been putting some great
efforts
into that um
and so what else is going on well the um
my graphic novel that i'm working with
with core nielsen
we um we are
really moving along on that on on that
uh on that front what's been great
is that uh that
this is actually been positive like this
weird clampdown has been
positive because because court is
working from home then he has a bit more
time to work on the pages so we've seen
things
come kind of speed up we might have
found
our colorist i put out on social media a
few pages
i think i put out one page that he
colored which was just beautiful
uh i don't know his name is felipe
carton i hope i'm pronouncing that right
and uh i think we're probably gonna have
the colors done by him unless
something happens and he doesn't want to
do it or doesn't have time or whatever
but for now
we're pretty excited about what he came
up with in terms of color
um what else is going on
um this month the uh the may patron only
video
is a kind of deep dive into dante and
the divine comedy
and uh i did it with a scholar from
mcmaster's university who's an expert on
an italian culture so we kind of dive
into dante and talk about
the how this universal pattern appears
in the comedy and how it's related to
other writers such as
of course a gregor nissa um and senate
from the syrian but also some muslim
authors like ibn arabi who wrote a
similar text
about a century before so maybe a bit
less than a century before
so all right so we're gonna we're gonna
go guys we're gonna start as usual what
do i usually do is i start
as you know people who support me 10
more you get to ask questions in advance
and i'm going to go through the
questions on my website on patreon and
on subscribe star
and then when we're done i will go
through the super chat
and see what's there sadly i know a lot
of people might be annoyed that i
not answering questions directly from
the chat it's just
it's just too hard and too much um
these questions that are coming in i
already i already have like
almost 30 questions in the uh the
advanced question so it's hard to answer
anymore
so sorry about that guys um all right so
here we go
okay so first question on my website
so bogdan asks thanks for doing these q
a jonathan they've been so helpful for
me
and my and many others in the last few
years thanks
my question is is it incorrect from an
orthodox christian
perspective to venerate pagan gods
spirits in the same way we venerate
saints through icons
i have recently been thinking that the
first commandment does not deny the
existence of other gods but rather state
that we should not worship these gods as
the highest
in your talk with benjamin voice on art
and orthodoxy you said something similar
when addressing jordan peterson's tweet
about the nature of god
that these god spirits exist sometimes
as principalities
and have consciousness and personality
in that case
how should we behave in regard to these
entities can you point me to some
writings
of theologians or church fathers on this
subject thanks again
so the way
to understand this is that no you should
not
venerate uh pagan gods and pagan spirits
as a christian because
these gods they are i kind of sometimes
i use the word wild principalities
you could say demons or principalities
that are not connected
to that are that are not connected to
the main narrative that aren't connected
to the story you know
that are fallen principalities as a
christian
and so and so the best way to understand
it is that
we as christians we do have the notion
that there are principalities
that order the world and that act as
let's say as patrons for different
aspects of reality
but these are angels right they're
they're they're angels
and so in the christian story you have
the idea that there are
angels which are submitted to the
highest
god and who are you know are submitted
to god
and so are acting according to his will
manifesting the will of god and then you
have the idea that there are also
fallen angels or demons or
principalities that
are creating parallel hierarchies that
are
that are or creating upside down
hierarchies that are
taking power for themselves that are
trying to
to attract uh power to themselves
something like that
and so the best way to understand it is
that
we are not we're not meant to venerate
these these smaller things
we we can recognize god
in his angels we can see god in his
angels there are a few angels in the
orthodox church to which we
that we venerate that we ask for uh
intercession
these are usually angels that have
manifested themselves explicitly
in scripture but we tend not to
emphasize that too much and it can get
it can get tricky when people do that
you know because it it creates this
strange kind of angiologies and
and it also usually ends up looking like
magic somehow
um and so the best way as a christian is
to
venerate the the angels that are
recognizing tradition as being
legitimate angels because we have
manifestations of them in scripture or
are very strongly in tradition
and then then you can venerate the
saints because they
are also acting as
principalities to a certain extent that
they are reigning with christ and so
in the catholic church you see a little
more because in the catholic church you
really have this idea that saints become
patrons of certain areas of reality that
that as we are the body of christ and
that we are
ascending let's say into christ that we
are becoming like christ and we are also
reigning with christ that we you know
christ talks about that
the idea that you know that
the disciples will be reigning with him
you know in the kingdom
and so you can see that in the notion
that then saints will become
according to their story according to
their own pattern
then they will become patrons of that
pattern of that aspect of reality
um that's a little more you see that
more in the catholic church
in orthodoxy it's it's more fluid it's
not as systematic just like
everything is not as systematic and in
orthodoxy as it is
in uh in the catholic church so
hopefully that
answers that so
pluma asked did you ever have a red pill
moment in regards to symbolism
um of course yeah and i i i think i've
mentioned that before
i mean my the moment that really
sh shifted me is you know matt's here my
brother and i we were reading different
things
we're kind of on different sides of the
question reading different authors
different
interested in different things and then
one day
matsier read a book called the crisis of
the modern world by
renegade who's a french french author
and he he just said jonathan you have to
read this book you
have to read this and i remember when i
read it
it just it really was like a redfield
moment it's like it just
reading that little book's not very long
and it could have been written yesterday
to be honest it just changed the way i
thought i could just feel it happening
as i was reading the book it was
completely
just shifting my mind and uh
yeah and then there was just no looking
back from there and i mean
since then i've kind of distanced myself
from that author but
nonetheless i have to admit that it was
by reading him
that uh that it started so
um so david flores
asks what is the symbolism of hot and
cold water
somebody says they hear a pop in my
microphone let me push the microphone a
bit a bit
further away from me
all right so what is the symbolism david
flores asked what is the symbolism of
hot and cold water
so this is something i was talking about
this today i was
talking to neil degrade today who's in
the chat as dirt poor robbins
and we were talking about i was trying
to try to explain
the issue of it's still clipping
okay i'm gonna try to adjust the mic
guys
is it better like this is it still
clipping turn gain down a bit that's
what i did
hopefully it's okay is it better
still hot what the heck
all right so i'm turning the gain really
way down
is this better is this still clipping
guys
i just want to make sure this is okay
all right it's a little better all right
talk talk sounds fine
what okay all right so hopefully this is
gonna be okay if it's still clipping
guys
write it down still clipping so it might
be
it might be uh it might be youtube
that's doing that's
struggling with this
independence impotence mismatch
so after the gain way down now
not clipping it's a little worse than
before what the heck
this is very annoying i want this to
work
try unplug replug all right let's try
that man sorry guys
all right let's try to unplug this
all right i unplugged it and plugged it
in
well i think it's gonna be as good as it
gonna get guys
still no i don't have my phone with me
so it can't be the phone
it's youtube same problem on other feeds
all right okay
so we'll do what we can guys
all right i will try to speak very
softly i'll try to say very softly
okay so i'm being told that this is
going on
this is going on on other channels all
right so let's try to speak softly i
tend to speak loudly anyways
speak too loudly anyway so
embrace the lo-fi asmr symbolism
so i can't do it i can't do the asmr
things
i have to whisper i'll start making
whisper sounds
be very disturbing symbolism and asmr
all right okay here we go
okay here we go so let's focus on the
questions now
no no more joking around okay so david
flores says
uh what is the symbolism of hot cold
water so yes i was talking about that
today
and it has to do with this this question
of fractal so what happens is that every
aspect of reality has
although it manifests something there's
also
then you when you go inside it then you
can find subtlety
which will divide into different aspects
so it's the same with
uh something like fire so fire has light
but it has
heat and those two things act as
complementary right and so it's the same
if you have something like cold water
and hot water then the cold water
is more akin to let's say
water and then hot water would be more
akin
to light or more akin to fire you know
but it's not the same but it's just that
in the symbols of water
it separates again into two um
so that is the best way to understand it
and so you can understand that for
example
water water dissolves and fixes
right depending on the circumstance
but if you separate it then you can see
that water when it's cold will fix
when it's hot will dissolve and so you
can understand that
fire also does that it also fixes
and uh and um and dissolves depending on
the situation
and so you can go into this to the the
symbolism
and you can tend to you can separate it
into
different more opposites within the of
the thing itself
so hopefully that makes sense
all right so josh the mover says
what do you make of the end is nice
section of youtube and that whole
mindset
i presume they are the clock that's
correct twice a day
but then alex jones predictions come
true more often than cnn predictions
strange world if we're truly in the
upside down clown world is it perhaps
time to make the fringy
do to take the fringy doomsayer
seriously um
the thing about the thing about
the kind of end is ni aspect is that
the the pattern by which these types of
stories or these types of perceptions
present themselves is usually not
totally off right it's not totally off
it's just that sometimes it's taken so
explicitly that
it ends up being strange but you know
for example
you know i've i did a video on on 666
symbolism
and some of it i could see that
the intuitions that when i was younger
people were having about
the idea of a microchip or the idea
of uh you know that you would have a
code bar when i was younger people would
say like are they going to print a code
bar on your hand or your forehead
you know that they'll scan and so it's
like
the actual predictions are are often
a bit off but the intuition of the idea
of
something which is calculating you
something which is accounting for you
completely that your your all of your
being reduced to a number
is something which it seems like it has
it has a right intuition and so there's
a lot of that going on
right now like a lot of the weird
conspiracy theories that are
coming out regarding the situation right
now
um a lot of them are excessive in
their details but are not necessarily
excessive
in their intuition about the pattern
and so you know there's some
there are some things which probably if
i talk about i'm afraid that i'm just
gonna get
i'm gonna get banned from youtube so
many videos have been
are being deleted from youtube if they
say certain things or if they talk about
certain things but i might
i'm not sure how to deal with this but
there's some of the intuitions people
have had about
you know about the founder of microsoft
and his
attempts you know to get involved in
this
there are some intuitions about that in
terms of the way that they're
thinking uh the problem
of the problem of the supplement and i
talk about the problem the
the positive aspect of the the garments
of skin i've talked about the positive
aspect of vaccines
but there's also a negative aspect and
there's also a negative aspect of this
adding of layer of death on the on the
outside it's that it's also
it's also it's also the place in which
something from the outside can come in
right it's also
it's also the the darkness
of this layer on the outside is also a
place of subterfuge it's a place of
trickery and so
so the way that people are thinking
about it is not completely off right and
so
it doesn't mean that that's exactly
what's happening or that people can
guess the intentions of everybody that's
what i often get
annoy me about a lot of these theories
is the way that people somehow
without the information they they
tend to guess the reason for things but
like i said
a lot of the intuitions are right so i
might make a video about this at some
point and just take the risk
that uh that youtube's gonna ban it but
we'll see or maybe i'll make it put it
up on bit shoot and then try to spread
the link around or something
but uh but right now i it seems like
there's very little point in doing that
i'll just get i'll just get banned so
yeah um
okay so i was talking very and kind of
very darkness with terry
only people that have been watching my
content for a while are
probably going to understand what i just
said in my last answer but you know
sorry guys
for now that's what that's what's going
to happen all right so luke fleischman
says
hey jonathan thanks for everything maybe
a silly question but i was curious if
there are similarities between the
giants
nephilim and the fool and if there are
how might they intersect
i have some thoughts on this but curious
on what your take is thanks
well i mean they they intersect in the
sense
that the the nephilim
are in a way uh they're an excess
they're a monster
they're an exception so that is
something that you find in the fool or
the clown this idea of being
exceptional and of being
you know of being a caricature of
something
and so the nephilim in a way because
they're too big
the idea of giants in general but it's
not just giants also
all the whole symbolism of giants or
dwarves like those usually are
the same symbolism it's just just like
an excess in one direction
a big or an excess of small like a that
you have a caricature
of a of a of a of a person
and so that is something which is
related to the fool
as well all right
so keenan cronin asks what do paul and
the fathers mean
that we should pray without ceasing or
continuously it seems linked to adam's
walking
with god in the garden but do you think
it's ever possible to get to that point
in this life where we are truly praying
without ceasing
i mean some saints have definitely
reached that
i not myself but the whole idea
the whole practice of hesicasm and the
practice of
um the prayer of the heart
has to do with the this idea of praying
without ceasing
so when you look at what some of the
hesychastic fathers talk about the
mystics of the orthodox church they have
this idea of the prayer of the heart
and so the notion is to pray
first consciously so they pray a it's a
it's a simple prayer it's lord jesus
christ
the son of god have mercy on me a sinner
or sometimes it's shortened to just lord
jesus christ have mercy on me
um or sometimes just lord jesus christ
but the idea is that there's a
there's a basic prayer which is
structured it's structured as
the pattern of reality maybe one day i
can do a video on that but it
it's structured in the sense it's
structured as a rhythm
so it's like an it's like a it's like an
opening yourself up
bringing in and then also then kind of
asking forgiveness for
for for your incapacity let's say so
it's like a
it's like a up and down anyways
the point is that the saints when they
pray that they'll pray it
like they'll pray that prayer and then
they'll make it
fit with their breathing and so they
pray and they breathe at the same time
and then what you see in the text is
that at some point the prayer enters
into the heart which means that
the whole being of the person becomes
prayer
and so they at some point the prayer
becomes like
the pattern of all their actions and so
behind
all their actions there's this basic
pattern
that has been written on their hearts
and then everything they do
come and becomes a version of the prayer
every action they pose
becomes a repetition of that prayer and
their
whole being becomes prayer and so that's
what you see that's what you see in the
text that's what you see
in the descriptions of those that have
been transformed
that way and so i think it's possible
because we have many testimonies of
people that have gone through
this transformation but it is not easy
and it is not something that you should
go about willy-nilly
and uh and uh it's something that you
need someone to guide you
on the path to so
all right
okay so eddie t asked why in the bible
do some men such as job
render their clothes and shave their
heads when they get bad news
um
in that sense in that sense i've talked
to you about
how nakedness is there are two nakedness
there's two versions of nakedness
there's two versions of nudity
there's one version of nudity which is
the nudity in the garden
which is innocence a nudity of innocence
and then there's a nudity of scandal and
the nudity of scandal is well
it's mostly you know the nudity that you
would experience if you went outside and
took your clothes off
um and so you see that in the story
i've talked about this before as well
you see that in the structure of genesis
where
you have adam and eve that are naked in
the garden and
then they fall they have to cover
themselves then you have the whole story
you have the flood
and that after the flood you have noah
who gets drunk
and and removes his clothes in his tent
and then is
his son sees him naked and that is seen
as a
as a shame as something that's a
shameful nakedness okay and
then in scripture you'll see all these
references to the idea that you should
not
see the nakedness of your father or your
mother
and so this idea that if you let's say
like if you have intercourse with your
father's wife you know uh or your
brother's wife
then it's seeing the nakedness of your
of your brother
right and that is a form of shaming it's
like you're entering into
a shameful a shameful revelation
okay something like that right and it's
the same reason why
we hide the two opposites like you hide
the you hide this mystery
that's in the cup in the altar
right you hide that mystery those are
the things you hide the mysterious thing
but there's something else you hide
you also hide when you go to the
bathroom you hide that stuff too
right and so there's this weird thing
about the two extremes right
and so when you see characters that do
things like
like rip their clothes off shave their
head
put ash on their head it's too similar
to signal
their lowness to signal that they are
really really at the bottom
right that they are it's almost like
they're shaming themselves they are
they they are doing it to
to annihilate themselves right to kind
of annihilate themselves in front of
everybody
it's something like that
and then you see that in in in
christianity you see
moments where that same action
of reign of like let's say removing your
clothes
in public which is an act of shame that
that act is joined with the myst the
mysterious one
and then it it's very odd like saying
france of assisi would do that
you know and he would tell his his
followers to do that when he started on
his journey
he he disrobed himself in public and he
would ask his
and it was to shame like it was for him
to be
to be the lowest of the low and in that
descending
he was able to connect that with with
the highest
but that's yeah that's tough that's
tough
don't do that guys don't do it what
saint francis did just
it's not most of the time it's not good
all right okay so let's keep going okay
uh it seems a white ear to ask it seems
like
modern non-denominational churches view
cultural relevance as an extension of
the mission
work of saint paul who became all things
to all people for the sake of the gospel
these churches see themselves as
speaking the cultural language
in terms of music visual art and
branding social media engagement etc
in your opinion is there any merit to
this approach as a church
or is any step in the cultural relevance
direction is
a step away from what the church is
intended to be i wrestle with this
question
thank you for your thoughts now this is
what i think about that
now if you look at if you look at early
church
if you look at the early practices of
the church one of the things that they
did was exactly
this they transformed
rome into a christian
city or a christian not just rome but
rome as a
whole idea of the hellenist hellenistic
city
they transformed that idea into a
christian ideal
and they did that by taking the forms of
the romans
and filling them with a new meaning okay
um and so you can see for example that
the church structure the basilica
that the christians use in the fourth
century is
a building that existed before it was
like a public square building
it's kind of a public building that
existed in rome and then
the church took that symbolism and
transformed it
in the basilica there was an apps at the
end just like in the church
and now the apps in the in christianity
has taken on a
whole more like a fuller meaning that
was there in the roman times okay so yes
that is possible and that is exactly
what christianity does
now the problem with the modern way of
doing it and some people might disagree
with me
but what i've seen is that
it's almost like a it's almost like a
reverse
it's almost like an ups it's like a
weird reversal where
it's not so much that they take
the forms of rome
and they fill them with light you could
say
it's rather that they take the light and
they diminish it
so that it's going to fit in these these
vulgar forms and so that's why
read read a hymn from
the 10th century
and then read a hymn from
you know some mega church
and it's embarrassing like it is
embarrassing to see
how low the message has been dropped
it's you know you know the joke and the
simpsons about
you know it's just basically a just
basically a pop song
and you've just changed the word baby
with jesus like
that's what it feels like that's what a
lot of this stuff feels like
it's like you you reduce the light to
make it fit
and i think that that's not the right
way now i i don't think that it's
impossible
i don't think it's impossible to fill
these
forms with light to a certain extent i
just don't see a lot of people
accomplishing it and i see like i said i
see the opposite
happening um
so you know prove me wrong guys
i'd be happy to see things transformed
okay so
tan moose man what a name asks
what is the symbolism of wailing
mourning and why in other cultures
specifically in the bible have there
been professional whalers mourners
at events like funerals this has to do
with
it has to do somewhat with the symbolism
i talked about that someone asked about
disrobing you know whaling
is a form of noise making
which manifests despair because
it's not coherent a whale
is not musical a whale is not
is not meaningful in terms of of a song
so it doesn't have a it doesn't have a
rhythmic pattern
it also doesn't have words to it it's
like a it's a moan
it's a whale and so this moaning and
wailing
is is a manifestation of
the despair or a manifestation of the
mourning itself right of this
this this cro
this this kind of moment of
this moment of realizing death this
moment of
accepting death or or dealing with death
uh has to do with wailing you know
and so i think that that's why
you know and i think that it was
important for
people to to wail and to mourn
at funerals to fully realize
fully realize the the the the moment
um and i think that the idea of a
professional whale or mourner
was like uh
it was it was almost like it was it's
like putting gas in the car it was it
was
like getting people to do it you know
and so
it's just like you know it's not a
have you ever been with someone when
someone have you ever been in a
situation where
you know you're talking and things are
getting emotional then one person starts
to cry
and then you can't hold it back so then
you just lose it
right and i think that that was the
point of professional whalers
is to because they thought it was
important for people to cry
and to to to mourn that they had they
had someone come in to like jump start
the process
to get to get others to uh to
to engage um
all right so i think we're done for the
website
i'm going to move on to subscribe star
all right and so logos living asks hello
mr pejo
enjoyed your work for a long time can
you explain the symbolism of
saving yourself for marriage
why is celibacy until marriage important
for men
apologies if you've already covered this
in a different video
um so
man this would get tricky really fast
um
it's definitely it's definitely a
christian thing that's really important
to understand
a lot of people somehow think that this
is a this is like a universal biblical
value it's not you don't
see that at all in the old testament
there isn't at all this idea of
of uh at least men remaining celibate
you know until marriage that it was
somehow important
um in
in in the christian tradition you see in
in the works of the early fathers
the the importance of
celibacy has to do with the fact that we
need to reign in
our passions we need our passions not to
rule over us
and marriage is seen as a form of
asceticism
this is something which a lot of people
will struggle
to to understand but that is
the reason for for uh marriage
is to be is so that you
bind your passions into one relationship
so that they don't pull you in every
direction
and so the idea of of remaining a virgin
until you're married is exactly for that
reason it's
so that your passions are bound into
this one relationship first of all so
that
you don't scatter yourself you know you
don't
uh you don't have a wild scattering of
your
of your seed in terms of your attention
in terms of your passions in terms of of
the
of all that but then there's also the
idea that
in marriage marriage has a sacramental
purpose and
you also have this sense that the image
of the bride and the bridegroom that you
find in scripture that you that are
christ
and the church that saint paul talks
about now also enters into the symbolism
of the of the
of the marriage as well and so in
containing yourself and then
being united with one person who is your
body
then you are also participating in
the pattern of the church itself you're
reenacting
you're participating and you and it's a
form of spiritual transformation
so that's as much as i can say about
that
all right so nicola asks
zombie apocalypse trope seems like a
mockery of christ's resurrection in many
ways
yeah is there a chance that when people
imagine zombies
they are actually making a subconscious
effort to portray
hell they would find themselves in the
last judgment
is it possible that by mocking the
christ resurrection
zombie displays the flip side of it and
only the flip side of it
it's a it's a parody of the resurrection
the
the zombie is a residue of the
resurrection you could see it that way
the idea of the dead rising and the idea
of the dead
living again is really
a christian notion like the resurrection
is really a christian
a christian notion and uh
and so what you have in this is why you
know you have to understand that
because christianity is a union of
spirit
and body and it's that's why we don't
like gnostics because gnostics
degrade the body gnostics degrade
created
things and so christians no christians
believe that
that god and the world are meant to be
joined together and that
and that the body is meant to be
transformed
and to be to participate in the kingdom
somehow
and so when christianity goes awry
that's why
it's something like christianity which
also will give materialism
because it's as if the the value of
the created world remains you remove god
uh but then it starts to it also starts
to decay into fragment
and so the zombie apocalypse become the
ultimate caricature the ultimate you
know
residue of the notion of the
resurrection it's like a materialist
resurrection and it's
what it gives is a kind of living death
and and it all the tropes that i've
talked about in my different talk so
so that's how i see it
so xrd asks hi jonathan do you have
anything you haven't been
asked about and you'd like to talk about
maybe something that's too big for a
tweet
and too small for its own video take
care well i'd have to think about that
xrd because i don't know
i tend to talk about things when i think
about them
so i'll try to think about it until the
end of this if i think of something i'll
i'll mention it
the christian chad asks hi jonathan hope
you and your family are safe and well
i see on the internet a lot of
discussions taking place saying
things like all bad ideas come from
france
what and i'm sadly sympathetic to this
point of view
what is it that english speakers get
wrong about french speakers
oh mercy there are plenty ideas there
are a lot of bad ideas that come from
france
that is for sure but
you know there are plenty of bad ideas
that come from
english-speaking world as well you know
all of you guys
you know what the 60s that's your fault
french revolution we'll take that we'll
take that on us
you know but it's true that a lot of the
bad ideas came from
from france some people will say though
i i have to say some people will say
that the 60s were
influenced by by french thinkers
that were that were prevalent in france
maybe
okay we could maybe like jean-paul sapp
and all of those people maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe but um
there is something about france it seems
like france went off the rails
um and uh
it hasn't it hasn't come back but there
there are several frances and that's
something
that people don't realize it's kind of
like in the u.s
you know there is there is still a
counter-revolutionary france
it's still there there still is a there
still is a royalist france
there still is you know a southern
a spirit of objection to
the revolution in the south of france
for example it's still there
you know and a kind of hostility towards
the history of how french identity
imposed itself so
yeah but there are a lot of bad ideas
coming from france okay
so adrian malion asks hi giano
jono long time listener
first time questioner my my question is
about king arthur specifically
the round table is this not a
problematic structure more associated
with oligarchy and democracy
truly not fitting of a king who rules
with authority is this an incoherence
within the mythological structure
or is this problem played out within the
story for example
is the lack of proper authority the
cause of guinevere's unfaithfulness
there is a hierarchy of virtue
established within the story
how close the grail knights can approach
the grail proportionate to their sin but
why is the hierarchy of authority and
the story so mighty
so i would say that i don't think you're
right i think you're wrong
in terms of
the the cause it's
in the story it's seen that the sins
of the of the knights and including
the the unfaithfulness of sir lancelot
and the other sins that are that happen
that happen
they're the cause of the
this banding of the
of the round table right that the the
fact that the round table
is broken or that it's it's falling
apart it's
it's seen it as caused by the sins and
so the round table in the story is
definitely seen as something
positive um like so a way to understand
that
is to understand it in in some of the
words that christ
says there's a place in the scripture
where christ says
i i no longer call you my servants but i
call you my friends
and this is a really crucial moment
in scripture and it's a crucial moment
to understand
the purpose of hierarchy
and the purpose of this relationship
ultimately the purpose of god
is to call us into the party into
participation with god
the purpose of christ is that we be
united with him fully
to an extent that he can call us his
friends that we
are co-rulers with him and so now
this is a tricky thing because
you could say like king arthur can have
a round
table and king arthur
can have this sense of an equality
to the extent that all the people in the
table
don't take that for granted so i i
always say something like
when christ says to the disciples i no
longer call you my servants
i call you my friends this the disciples
it was true and it created a weird kind
of round table situation
but it would not have been proper for
the disciples to say
my buddy jesus like some people do today
that would not have been appropriate
it's like the upper the higher party is
the one
that calls you up to participate in
their authority
it is not those that are below that are
that are there to
to let's say jump up and you know take
their place
in the round table you know and so i
think that that's
that's the way to understand the round
table is to understand it that the
that the union between the king and his
knights was so perfect
that the knight the king was able to
bring them into his authority that he
was able to make them participate
in his authority uh in a way that
created this this kind of this kind of
equality and so
you can see it even this is going to be
tricky for a lot of people
maybe i might be pushing it a little bit
but you can sort of see that in
the idea of the of the trinity itself
which is that
there is this this notion that there
that there is a hierarchy of
of roles in the in the uh
in the trinity in christ declares often
that he is there to do the will of the
father that
he is completely submitted to the father
but in that
submission to the father there's there's
an equality also
that is manifesting itself you know
because
he's fully he's fully fully manifesting
everything of the father
and so maybe that's the best way to
understand it
maybe not that's what i've got for you
guys all right okay here we go
so samuel asks how important
do you think a good translation of the
bible is the symbolic understanding
can we lose the symbolic pattern of a
story to a skewed translation i'm
thinking of in particular traditional
jewish concepts like shiol
and gehenna different translations for
behemoth
being water buffalo or wild beasts and
job or names for god like elohim
hope you're well all the best angles yes
i i agree
i think that i think that
the quality of a translation is
extremely
important and so you will that's why you
will see
for example if you look at the story of
the 70
of the septuagint you will see that you
know according to tradition
the 70 the septuagint was translated by
70 scholars
and they all translated it on their own
independently and they all came to the
same
translation right so that's kind of like
the the
the tradition or the the legend around
the septuagint but what it
shows you is how important a translation
is
that's why if you you know you've met
english-speaking protestants sometimes
you'll find
them who will say things like you know
the king james is inspired right or
you find catholics who say that too like
that that jerome's translation
is inspired right it's inspired by god
and so that's why
so it is it's super important because it
it and first of all there's a question
of authority um
and second of all there it will flavor
the christianity you know it will
it will affect the way that that
christianity lays itself out
i think one of the advantages of the
modern world
it's a disadvantage too but it can be an
advantage for someone who is
traditionally minded
and has doesn't have the desire to
undermine
christianity then some something you
know like uh
bible the the the bible websites that
have you know
that have transliterated versions that
you can click and you can see the the
septuagint you can see the
the uh the hebrew with the english and
you can look at
strong's uh strong's definitions and
all of that it can be really useful you
know because
there are meanings in scripture that
that might have been veiled for a little
while and that we can
we can notice you know and there are
there are modern translations today
which seem to to have ill
intent in their translation or rather
adjusting intent you know in in uh
in genesis in the creation narrative
there's a place where when god creates
the the fish
it says that he created the sea monsters
and the sea monsters is that it's a word
it's a
tannin which means the sea serpents
and so in genesis it says god created
the sea serpents the word
means serpent it's basically saying the
you know god created the dragons on that
day
and now in in like niv translations and
all these
these new translations they just write
sea creatures the large sea creatures or
something like that
but you're missing the whole point if
you don't
if you don't have the idea that it's a
sea serpent and that it's a giant sea
serpent and that
lay other places in scripture that
servant sea serpent is called the
leviathan
you know and that these these sea
monsters you're just missing the whole
point you're not
you're not gonna understand what's going
on in that verse if you
if you miss that um it's not gonna make
you be completely
out i mean you can still
you can still be a christian and
everything it's just it's just that
you're missing out
all right okay so dorothy kk asks
hi jonathan thanks for all you do i've
learned really much since i follow you
on youtube
have a question about the dancing sun
miracle at fatima
and other marian apparition places i've
been told
what is the symbolism behind it it
reminds me of john the baptist dancing
in the womb as mary visits
elizabeth one could call that first
apparition of mary as the mother of god
but why the son
i don't i i'm gonna
i'm gonna betray how orthodox i am
because
i've never been interested in the fatima
in the fatima miracle so i don't know
what it is
so i don't know like uh i don't know
what what it is that happened
um
i'd have to look i'd have to look at it
because i i don't know
is is it even recognized
is it recognized the the the the
the fatima i think it is i think it is
recognized
um so anyways i would have to look into
it i don't know
i don't know about about that miracle so
i don't know exactly what what it is and
what happened
so i'd have to check that out sorry
all right so i think
i think i'm done with
i think i'm done with subscribe star so
i'm going
into patreon here we go
all right we've got a lot of questions
guys so
okay so daniel demarco asked hi jonathan
thank you for all your time and wisdom
also thank you to mature
i'll try to pass that on is symbolic
interpretation in particular
a vision of the structure of reality
something we can apply
to our everyday life can it help us when
interacting with family friends and
co-workers can it help
guide our decisions and how we spend our
time
or the direction of our careers if so
would you please give an example
or is it just less exclusively a tool
for seeing meaning in the bible and
other ancient or symbolic text
and that meaning in turn is what we
apply to our everyday life
um no i think i think that
symbolic living you could say it that
way
is definitely a way that is definitely
something that you can use
to to structure your life and you can do
it
it mostly becomes important to the to
the extent
that our world has become so unbalanced
you know and so wild that
you that we've kind of lost
we've kind of lost these basic things
which ancient people used to take for
granted
and so i do think that that
for example you know when i talk about
the balance between unity and
multiplicity
when we talk about hierarchy you know
you know when we talk about like i talk
sometimes about
how you organize a hierarchy in your
home like your home is organized as a
hierarchy that
your world has this hierarchical this
hierarchical
um structure and so
if you can live in that it does a lot of
things
first of all it helps you to feel calm
knowing that there's
an implicit order that's there but also
one of the things that i'm trying to
help people understand
even in when i talk about hierarchy is
also the role
and the purpose and the value of the
margin and so
one of the things it can make you can
help you is
if you are someone who tends to be
chaotic and
and uh attracted to the margin let's say
it can help you understand why we do
need these patterns of order you need
your home
to have order to a certain extent you
need your family
to have order you need there to be
hierarchy in
in your your life but if it's the
opposite if you're someone who is
hyper organized in this it can also help
you to understand
the the need for this potential on the
edge the need
to leave that be the need to also
engage the spice of life
to a certain extent and that this is
also part of reality
so i do think that it can help you
live your life
all right so angel asks i'm currently
reading christian and oriental
philosophy of art
after seeing it in your book
recommendation list and you're watching
one of your older q a's you said
that there were some things in it you
found to be problematic and you didn't
agree with
my question could you elaborate and what
is the right mindset to have
when reading that book in order to not
get lost in the weeds
or be misguided thank you um i'm not
sure i remember
what it is that i said
okay yes there are a few things in
kumaraswamy's
vision that i don't totally agree with
one is
he he does have a tendency to to
favor the abstracting qualities of art
and so he tends to talk about for
example an example he gives
he gives this example of a maori uh
chieftain who's asked to paint a
self-portrait of himself
and then another guy paints a draws a
portrait of the same
chieftain and the married chieftain
because he's his face is all tattooed
and so the maori chieftain draws the
tattoo on his face in a pattern like a
perfect pattern
and so it's like this abstract pattern
with eyes you know
and then the other guy does like a
realistic portrait and then
what what kumar swami shows is to what
extent
the maori chieftain understands the
transcendent and that he understands
that his being
that his self you know that is he would
you know that
as a something like his uh his achma you
know
like his the core of his being
how it's more important than the details
or the
you know and so i agree with that to a
certain extent but i think that
in the christian tradition what we find
is a balance between the two so
for example in islamic architecture you
have like a square with a dome right you
have
an octagon with a dome whereas in
christianity you also have this pattern
of the square and the dome but there's
then there's also
room for you know improvisation
within the the very very tight pattern
and so i think that that i believe the
highest form of art
is the unity of the two and a kind of
breathing in and breathing out relating
to the abstract pattern
and then it's it's kind of application
to the world and it's
it's molding to to the specif the
specifics of reality
and so that's one thing um but it's
still worth reading like
you know you're not gonna find a lot of
of
theory art theory books that are that
interesting
uh you know in this in the sense and
cooper swami is a genius like he was and
he was a
he was an actual genius so he's worth
reading
um so paul dumas asked hi
i'm currently reading the crisis of the
modern world strange we talked about
that before
by renegado and after that i plan to
read the reign of quantity and the sign
of times and symbols of sacred science
what should i be careful about and what
should i pay attention to uh regarding
reading to get the most out of it in
your opinion so
so guinea is probably had the best
symbolic mind in
in the 20th century for sure i mean his
his capacity to perceive symbolism
is really unmatched i believe
you know also because he's able to
perceive all kinds of different
symbolisms like if you you see my
takes they're usually very space related
i usually use
space-related geometric symbolism is
mostly what i tend to engage with
whereas
was able to view all kinds of aspects of
symbolism that
that kind of escape me like i number
symbolism is something that i don't get
into so much anyways he's a
he was a genius but he was also
he was also off on a lot of points and
he was mostly off
i think on his desire to
hit the i think he was off in
the the fact that he was able he didn't
realize that what he was doing was going
to bring about a kind of weird
syncretism
and you can see that the perennialists
the people who kind of follow his
writings they become like
it's as if they're in another religion
if there's this weird perennial religion
and they they talk almost with disdain
about
the actual traditions and they kind of
they think that they stand above all
these religions and that they're somehow
above them
and i find that really distasteful i
find it not only distasteful but i find
it
i find it bad for your soul like it's
just not good
and so so there's a lot of things that
you know
gets wrong in in that sense um
and you know also you know i think that
i i am a christian like i think that
guino also
had in him a strain of anti-christian
thing that he took from his you know
that
he took from where he came from he he
had
backgrounds and occult stuff and in
freemasonry and stuff and so
he had a kind of weird anti-christian
a weird anti-christian bent that i just
can't
i just can't accept i do believe that
that
that you do not have a higher mystery
than than
the uh then communion but there just
isn't the the symbolism is all there and
i don't know how you could see it like
there is no there is nothing that
contains more
than than uh than communion so
anyways that's what i think i think that
he a lot of people have said this about
him i think he didn't understand
christianity
well enough uh all right so leftistness
asks how do you know that christian
moral claims are based on a transcendent
ethic instead of based on man's
collected knowledge
of what best allows them to survive
their environment
you lose explanatory power when you try
to describe that which is transcendent
in material terms if so how do you
rationally
justify your moral positions um
well i would say i would say that
christianity isn't about ethics i'm
gonna have to just say it out
i mean i think i've been flirting around
this for a while christianity is not
about ethics christianity is not
this idea that somehow religion is about
ethics it's just wrong it's just not
uh that's not what it's about uh
i'm not saying it's unethical it is
the basic of what we consider to be
ethics today
i think comes from
comes from christian understanding but
christian i don't think that
christians have moral claims i don't at
least not
when i look at christianity through the
length of orthodoxy i don't see
moral claims what i see
what i see is that all the law
is is resolved
into two statements love god
love your neighbor right and loving your
neighbor
is the means by which you manifest your
love for god
and everything comes out of that
all of the moral positions will will
come out of that
that's what i that's what i think and so
and so the christianity
and the so the rules are there to just
point like all the laws in the old
testament
and all the laws in the in the new
testament or in the church are there to
or point us to a way of being
not not a bunch of stuff you need that
you're allowed or not allowed to do it's
a way of being
that transcends any any
action or any question of what's right
or wrong or all of this now i'm not
saying right or wrong doesn't exist
it all of this is is real but that's not
that's not the thrust of christianity
the thrust of christianity is the
transformation
of people of of bringing people
into the life of god bringing
communities
into the life of god through the the
lives of the prayer
the the the love of the saints for each
other
and that's what that's what it's about
um so
so yeah so that's you know that might be
a reason if you
if you if you listen watch my videos
you'll notice that i almost never talk
about morality
uh because i find morality to be
to be secondary to what christian in in
christianity
like i said i'm not saying that i'm not
saying that there aren't things which
are moral or immoral
but that's not the if you start with
moral claims then you
then you lose you can't win if you start
with
worship and you start with transcendence
and you start with
with the desire to be united to to
the the the triune god and to be
united to your neighbor in a manner
which manifests
the unity of the of yourself with god
and even the unity within god
within god himself that then will
create a moral world that will
that will tumble and that will like come
out as
morality you know and like i said
there's the rules like there are plenty
of rules in the church there are plenty
of
of rules that say this is a sin this is
not it's in that's not what it's about
but
it has to go to go higher or else
or else it doesn't doesn't matter
um
and i and and and to remain in your
question i would say that that
doesn't contradict the idea that it's
also that that it also reflects man's
collected knowledge of what
to allow for them to survive that i
don't see i see no contradiction
in the fact that that it would also
manifest itself like that
right that they're just they're just
different levels
all right so simola belge says
could you talk about the dog-headed say
christopher thanks in advance
well i think i've talked about some
christopher quite a few times
so what i'm going to do is i'm actually
going to hold back a little bit
as i'm working on this this comic book
about
kind of a very very let's say
loose retelling of the legend of saint
christopher i am going to
when i when we get close to putting it
out what i'll probably do
is i'll make a bunch of videos um
talking about
the uh the meaning of saint christopher
in the meantime if you want i wrote a
series of article
on a series of articles on the orthodox
art journal
called the meaning of the dog-headed
icon of saint christopher i think it's
called
if you write my name in saint
christopher and google you'll find
that article i wrote two articles on on
the meaning of that
all right so jl asked
hey jonathan i've been observing a
recent increase in people
engaging with the work of oxford england
owen barfield
i was wondering if you have given any of
his thought
your attention and if so how does it fit
with what you study and teach
if at all um
no i've not read owen barfield at all
and a lot of people are telling me that
i should
so maybe i should but no i i i just
haven't read owen barfield
so you'll just be another person telling
me
that i should that i should be going by
bar field
all right keep going
try to where are we okay okay charlie
longoria asked am i correct to separate
the two beasts
god chose job the behemoth and leviathan
symbolic representations of chaos and
order
the bmw opting order and leviathan being
chaos no i don't think that's right
i don't think that's right um i think
the way of understanding
the the beasts
is to understand the the aspect
of both the earth and
the sea that are
destructive or that are at the limit of
what they are you know at the limit of
what the earth are
is and that the limit of what the sea
is they're both images of that
and so in a way they're both images of
if you if you of potentiality right of
like raw potentiality
that if you that you can't control
right and so that's why there are kind
of these beasts on the edge
and so that's true as much about earth
as it is about ocean as it is about to
see you know
they're related in that sense
all right so you could have you could
have
beasts of of the four elements something
like that you know
you could have different beasts that
represent the rawness of the
of the elements right the the
the potentiality
all right so vic serda asks
while reading isaiah 14 9 i was confused
to see a reference
to thrones in sheol which to me implies
a sort of
hierarchical structure within the realm
of the dead
what do the thrones in passage in the
passage mean
i'd have to read it
so he talks about the realms of the dead
below
is all a stir to meet you at your coming
it rouses the spirits of the departed to
greet you
all those who were leaders in the world
it makes them rise
from their thrones all those who were
kings over the nations
um so i don't know i don't know
if the the purpose is really to
to talk about
i mean you could understand it that you
could kind of understand it that way you
could kind of
understand the notion that you have
the throne below and so
the idea is that you have death below
you have the dead below you have
uh the the that which is
is below and is stirred up
as god comes so god comes from above
right
and all that is below these dead spirits
this
death all of this rises up
in order to join with god in order to
greet god okay
so so this has to do with the idea of
the
of potentiality or chaos at the bottom
rising up right of let's use that
emerging to meet the pattern so so it's
like you
pull the earth out of the ocean that god
does that in genesis
that you gather the dead up right and
then
god comes down and joins with him so you
could
understand that the imagery in in this
so you have
the dead below and the throne below
and those who are the kings of the
nations
are below the nations are below and
they're
they're all of this is below and then
god comes
and all of the past and all of that is
dead
rises up to join to to be united
again or to be to find life again or to
to
so it it just follows the same pattern
of
of creation just follows the same
pattern of creation um
so that's how i would i would see it so
i don't think the idea is to show
the hierarchy in shield although i'm not
against the idea of there the hierarchy
and shield you see it in dante
uh but but rather it's mostly to
understand
that which is below that which is dead
rising up you know from death in order
to join with
that which is above you know so so a
seed
falls into the ground and then
all this dead stuff that's there rises
up
right and then it joins with the seed
the seed
forms it again gives it life again and
then that earth
that dead stuff becomes a tree right
it rises up because of a pattern that
a little seed that has a pattern in it
fell into the ground
and is it is bringing it up into into a
tree
um so that's an example of that maybe
give you
so that it i am always afraid because i
i always figure that you guys that have
been watching
these q a's that you know that that i'm
always talking about something but
sometimes i'm afraid because
the problem of of religious language is
that it's it
it's sometimes become so internal that
you know
people forget that it's actually talking
about something so i
i have to remind myself to give you
examples like that
in order to so that it's not just an
inner discussion about scripture but it
really is about how the world
lays itself out um
so sander couture asks what are your
main struggles at the moment
man you guys rarely ask personal
questions
uh i yeah things are things are crazy i
mean
everybody has weird struggles right now
because of this this lockdown but i
think that
you know uh i i know you guys know about
my
um the flood that we had last year so
we're actually just started rebuilding
our house
two weeks ago and so right now we're
like right into
the the thick of things um
and so it's a bit crazy because you know
i've had to borrow
huge amounts of money which is fine
because i've always been dead adverse so
i'm not in danger but i did have to
borrow huge amounts of money so that's
always stressful
and uh and also you know
i i right now one of my best friends
one of the people that i love the most
in the world um
who's just an amazing my cousin pascal
who's an amazing christian
and a wonderful father just a just like
just someone who you admire and
and that i've admired my whole life and
i you know we found out a few weeks ago
that he had stage four pancreatic cancer
and so
that's taken up a lot of my just
brain energy and and my prayer
and my tears so so that's what i've been
kind of that's what i've been kind of
dealing with you know he's young he's in
his 40s and uh just hit
like a like a like a freight train you
know
just trying to deal with that so so i'm
gonna go see him tomorrow i try to go
see him as much as i can
he lives about an hour and a half away
so it's not that easy to get there but
but uh but yeah so those are the those
are
my main struggles at the moment i would
say but more personal stuff
um all right
and so thank you for your prayers guys
thank you thank i see people
in the chat are saying they'll pray for
him so thank you
all right so christopher serretta asks
hey jonathan
in a cut chapter from dostoevsky's
demons the nihilist privately confesses
his misdeeds to the holy fool
the nihilist asks forgiveness and is
surprised when the holy fool asks his
own forgiveness in response
in sinning each man sins against all
each man
is at least partly guilty for another
sin
it pains me to strip down such a
beautiful passage but the essence
is in that one line is dossier
expressing a christian concept here or
is this more of his own philosophy
no i think he is i think
i think this is this is really hard
it's hard this stuff this aspect of
christianity is hard because it's just
really difficult to
uh to do you read it all the time when
the church fathers where they say
take other people's blame on you right
and uh it's like how do you do that it's
really
difficult you know within the world of
twitter like who does that
uh but the idea
is the idea is
that there is this is the strangest
thing it's like that
the idea is that there is a strange
power in
doing that like that if you can
take other people's
sins on you
a lot of people will say that this is
almost like blasphemous because it's
that's what christ did but there's
something about how
we can somehow participate in that that
we can take
the blame um
and that when you if you do that if you
do it properly if you don't do it
out of ill intent then you can
actually save people you can actually
that you can actually participate in
their salvation
because that gesture will transform them
you know
um and that if you
yeah yeah but that stuff is hard to
think about because
that's an aspect of christ which is just
you can see it like you can see because
that's it that's what christ did that's
what
christ did that but it's hard to
understand
i've never i rarely find people that i
felt when they're able to explain it in
a way
that is not just
a weird like a weird magic trick or
something like it's not a magic trick
there's something about
a deep deep pattern about reality which
is
in that mystery of the capacity to take
others blame on you and how it
transforms the world
um so yeah okay
robert smits asks robert smith sorry hi
jonathan i was wondering about what is
the symbolism of ecclesiastes 12
remember him before the silver cord is
severed
and the golden bowl is broken before the
pitcher is shattered at the spring
and the wheel broken at the well and
their dust returns to the ground it came
from and the spirit returns to god who
gave it
yeah that's it like that's it like
that's the symbolism guys that's that's
the
that's the that's the the symbolism of
everything right there
it's actually a really beautiful little
passage
so
so the idea is you have to remember
that's what forgetting is right
forgetting is
the cutting of a chord forgetting is the
breaking of
a bowl it's the shattering of a
picture that's what forgetting is a
broken wheel
think about a wheel so you have a wheel
you have a center
you have spokes right and the
the the wheel the outside of the wheel
has to remember
has to stay connected to the center the
string has to stay connected
to what it's attached to the ball has to
remain
attached together for it to hold what
it's going to hold
and forgetting is the breaking
a part of that and so the idea and the
ultimate version of that is
to remember before the dust
returns to the ground where it came from
that means you right
the dust going back to the earth means
you before you
break apart before your body dissolves
before the the line is cut you have to
remember god
and that is how things stay together
that is how the world remains together
and when that happens so when
memory is lost when
the unity is broken then the dust
returns to the ground
and the spirit returns to god there's a
separation
of heaven and earth so that's that's it
that's death death is the separation of
having a nerf
but if you remember god that's when
heaven and earth are united
and so it's a beautiful passage
all right guys
so justin seligman asks
hi jonathan how do you see your platonic
christian ontology work itself out
in gender hierarchies particularly those
of husband and wife
i'm asking as a husband and father and
as one who is tired of the ongoing
egalitarian debate in western
christianity as i don't think
either side has it right
um i think i think that
it's i've mentioned this before i i
think that
the christian vision of hierarchy is
not one which is not one where
like in that like for example in the
hindu hierarchy where
as you go down there is an absolute
devaluing
right as you go down there's like a
dilution as you go down but
rather the purpose of the hierarchy is
so that that which is above loves
that which is below and makes it
participate so
if you can see so you can see in in in
uh in the bible you'll see
two images about the relationship
between man and wife you'll see
a hierarchical relationship you see that
in saint paul
and uh you see it you know in different
patterns in the old testament
but you'll also see in genesis the idea
of you know the woman coming
from man's side and you'll find in the
church fathers the talk of how
you know the reason why god took the
woman from the man's side
is so that she would be equal to him and
so
it's the same question it's the same
reality
as the the the round table that we
talked about before
it's the same reality that that in the
relationship
between the husband and wife
the ultimate purpose is that it be
like the round table right that that the
man
takes his wife into his life
in a manner in which they become equal
he makes her
his equal but it's not a revolutionary
move it's not
uh you owe me give me what i'm owed
like you know i'm uh you know you're not
treating me the right way like
that kind of that so there's a
the purpose of the whole thing is so
that that
is that there be perfect unity and that
that unity does end up looking
something like equality
but it also but it can't be an equality
of like i said of um
quality of revolution like a
revolutionary equality so i hope this
makes sense hopefully you can get it to
make sense also
in in
because i talked about the round table
before because that's what it that's
what it's
it's the same the same pattern
all right so dionysus asked hello
jonathan
through contemplating the field of my
experience i can now see
how it is in the most fundamental level
comprised
of the manifestations of logoe meaning
i can also see how language the word can
be seen as the point where a logos
coalesces
but i can also observe that on
contemplating something deeply
new manifest to me before i attach a
word
to them so it seems that the logos is
intertwined with the word once it is
defined
before that point it is still manifest
and thus not always arising
from the naming as such how dependent is
the distinguishing of logoi
to concrete language could you share
your own observations thanks
yeah i think it's important what you're
talking about is important to understand
you know when when i talk about naming
um you could
you could use another word which might
be better identifying
right identifying is probably a better
word than naming
though naming has uh has has value
because
in scripture there's this speaking out
you know
um and so what you're doing when you
perceive the logoi is identifying them
right but it's it's a way in a matter of
the giving of name but it
doesn't have to be an explicit like
wording
um but it has to be an identity giving
or an identity realizing
realizing of identity okay um now
another aspect of that which is
important is that we need to understand
that there is a sense
of perfect language you would say
there's a sense in scripture of this
direct language which is
the idea that when god speaks
then reality is that which god speaks
there's no
there's no distance between the word of
god
and the manifestation and you you get
the sense also that when adam
named the animals he was also he was
identifying the animals right he was
participating in their
the revealing of their identities but
modern languages are not like that you
could understand that like modern
languages are fallen or something like
that
then modern languages have buffers
modern languages are
are systems built on systems built on
systems you know and so
they are far away from the primordial
language which we
can only imagine that would be a direct
naming they're
they're quite far and we we've taken
them farther still because we
we have let's say all these languages
which are built on
on systems built on you know on
different systems built on each other
and then now we have systems like
you know computers and and then they
have software and then
hardware and software and then software
on software and
so it's like all these languages just
keep piling up
you know and so refer we get further and
further away
from the notion of a direct direct
connection between identity
identifying and the logo the logos
um hope that makes sense that was a bit
abstract sorry
but the question was abstract so
all right so aj del torio asked hey
jonathan i'm a protestant who is
beginning to appreciate the mystery
of the bread and the wine sometimes i'd
be curious to hear
to say more on with the rituals around
receiving it in the orthodox church so
much of the liturgy consists of these
practices so if possible
i'd like to better understand the
significance of them thank you
um sure i mean i hopefully i will
one day there's so much to talk about aj
so hopefully i will get to more talking
about liturgy i
i've talked about liturgy you know here
and there
but um maybe one day we could do a deep
dive into
liturgical practice
so herman smith says does it seem
inevitable that as mankind mankind loses
its ability
to properly lower heaven as matthew puts
it we build machines to raise ourselves
further and further into
the material heavens i totally agree
with that i think
that that it is definitely inevitable i
think that
one of the things we're seeing in
modern techno society
is definitely a power babble motif you
know
and you see it especially especially in
this
weird ai idea you know the idea of uh
of the of how ai
will it will become sentient and that ai
will be
become like almost like a god you know
and you can see that that's really what
people think and um
so i agree you know and i think that if
you want to understand
all of it happened before like the story
i mentioned this in
a video which a lot of you didn't watch
it didn't get a lot of views maybe
because of
the title it was called how
art can help save the world or something
like that
and i wasn't just talking about art in
that video i was actually talking about
technology mostly um and techne
you know the idea of human building
human making
um and how in the time of noah you had a
cycle
of technology technology and that cycle
led to the flood and now we're repeating
the same cycle very similar you know
it's like
when when someone like sam harris says
that that
uh you know religious texts can't help
us today because
they don't talk about all the things we
have to deal with they don't talk about
nuclear weapons and
and all the the and all the stuff we
need to deal with and i'm like dude
you're you're wrong that the book of
enoch talks
exactly about all that it doesn't have
to talk about
specific technologies to talk about the
problem of
technology and the problem of the
modification of nature and what that
leads to
uh so yeah so check out that video if
you are interested
in that all right so jason
lindsay says is there any significant
difference between necromancy and the
creation of golems
or are they fundamentally the same thing
after hearing your description of
necromancy and its relationship to
archaeology
that is using dead residue as a means of
to influence the world
i can't help but see the creation of
golems as just another version of the
same process
the only real difference seems to be the
physical materials used to accomplish
the agenda
so is there a difference between zombies
and robots
would a cataloging history be a positive
form of necromancy
if not there is any positive form of
necromancy or goal
making i suspect the answer would look
something like resurrection thank you
for any insight into this
i think there's quite a difference
between necromancy and the
the story of the golem you know um
the story of the golem
is probably more related to
[Music]
it's related to creating an exterior
form
and giving it a life giving giving it uh
giving it a life and so
it has more to do with
creating a a weapon
or taking something for from the outside
and
using it as a guardian so let's say
like a good example of making a golem
that
so it doesn't become very abstract is
hiring a bunch of northern northern
barbarians
you know in order to fight for the roman
empire
right that's the creation of angola
because you're taking some from the
outside and you're trying to put enough
of your
life into it so that it will then defend
you from
the outside stuff right okay so that
would be more like the making of a golem
whereas necromancy
it's not complete i guess when i think
about it now i'm thinking it's not
completely unrelated
um because there is an
aspect in which that which comes from
the outside
is somewhat it's kind of dead to you to
a certain extent it's not part of your
your identity so there's something
related to that um
but necromancy seems to
have the the a kind of subversive
a kind of subversive goal in it you know
because
it's it is it's like a it's like the
creation of a monster so yeah you're
right
so the idea of a zombie is better right
so it's like you
you you raise this these dead things and
then they just start to
to eat at meaning and they start to
devour
the inside whereas the golem is meant to
like defend
you from the outside but not not the
necromancer the necromancer i think
is more like a like a is more like a
cannibal is more like it
trying to eat meaning from the inside
that's as close as it's gonna get
weird weird subjects to talk about but
all right so dom palermo says hi
jonathan
considering logos and the importance of
the word of god remembering christ
silently drawing
on the ground in response to the
accusers of the adulteress
and also silent on occasion in the face
of pilate and high priests
when asked for the truth what can you
share about the heavenly meaning of
silence what other
images point as guides for when silence
is appropriate or inappropriate
um well there is
this idea that silence is higher than
word like that science is this that
silence is the source
of speaking right and so
that's why monks are silent
that's why
you know and there's a sense that even
if you speak like you would have to
speak out of
the deep silence like that's where you
would have to speak out of
and not out of the chattering
voices that are in your mind you know
like the chattering thoughts
um and so silence is extremely important
it's extremely important um now
in the in the face of pilot
it's caught it's a little more
complicated because there is also
something about how
christ in in his ministry there's like a
dual aspect to him like
there's an aspect where he's hiding
himself from
from the world he's kind of hiding
he's hiding his true nature and then
there's an extent to which he's showing
it in some
secret moments so i think that
and it has to do also with like the
danger
of someone giving testimony for
themselves
and so i think that there's something
about how
christ remains silent is it has
something to do about his how his
divinity is hidden
is hidden in him um has something to do
with that
so luca azkovic asks what is
exactly the meaning of the quote again i
tell you it is easier for a camel to go
through the eye of a needle
than for someone who is rich to enter
the kingdom of god
is it really that impossible for a rich
person to enter the kingdom of god or is
there a higher symbolic meaning
i think there's definitely a higher
symbolic meaning in terms of the camel
um but i'm not gonna go into that now it
would be really complicated
it's that's that's going into really
complicated symbolism
um but i mean it's not
it's it's not in terms of the symbolism
it's not
that hard to understand the idea is
that so if you understand
the world as a wheel or as a mountain or
all of this
you know i've talked about this in
several instances where
if you want to reach the middle of the
wheel you have to move away from the
center so
there's a lot on the edge there's a lot
at the bottom of the mountain there's a
lot of mountain there's a lot of stuff
it's big and there's
quantity so in order to move towards the
kingdom of god you have to you have to
eliminate
and so that's what's so a rich person
it's difficult for them to do that
because they're big
they have stuff they have all this stuff
that they're attached to
so all the stuff they're attached to
they can't
get to the the little point
you know the little hidden seed that
is really the most important the pearl
in the field
the the you know the the mustard seed
all of these images of the little little
the little little is like the the
mystery hidden
inside the world but in order to
to access that you have to eliminate you
have to cut out
the fat you have to remove the fat or
else
you won't be able to to identify
the really important part you know um
so that's where all the aesthetic
practices in the church come from and
it's important to understand that it's
not
it's not wrong to be rich and you'll see
that
later also in in scripture like they're
in the christian tradition
it's not necessarily wrong to be rich
but it is makes it difficult because you
have all this
stuff that you're attached to and so but
then
always remember that when christ after
christ says that the disciples asked him
well then who can be saved and then
christ says
what's impossible to man is possible to
god so there's there's another mystery
in that as well which is that
you could say something like the whole
purpose of god is also
to get that camel to go through the eye
of a needle to like
that's also what the incarnation is like
that's what the ascension is the
ascension is like a camel going into the
eye of a needle so there's a mystery
like i said i don't want to go into it
too much but in that
text there's a lot there maybe one day
i'll write an article about it or
something
all right okay so isaiah hale says why
is an orthodox like a pirate
um well isaiah i know where you've got
that which is that andrew gould
in my interview with him
says that orthodoxy is a lot like
pirates
and uh i have to tell you i disagree
with him
for as much as i love andrew which is
why i said like
i will do another we'll do another um
interview and then i'll ask him to talk
about that but i don't agree
i don't agree that the orthodox are like
pirates at all
so i was really curious about how i like
what he meant by that so
so maybe one day i will do my have my
second interview with andrew and
then i can ask him why in the world
he thinks that the orthodox are like
pirates
um all right guys man it's 10
40. it's late it's late it's late all
right all right so let's let's go
quickly into the into the super chats
and see
and see what we got
[Music]
all right here we go let's see how many
there are
all right so
let's start with making i think i've got
the i think i've got the right
the right one
hopefully i'm not going into stuff
that's not all right so i think it
starts with
andrea johnson for five dollars usd
would you describe the afterlife how
would you describe the afterlife to
materialist what's wrong with saying
that death
is just lights out
well i've never experienced the
afterlife so i don't know how i would
describe it
i would describe it i would
i don't think there's an afterlife i
don't i don't know what that
i don't totally know what that word
means it's a very odd word
um
i would say that
i would say that life doesn't
identities don't totally depend on
i don't know how how to say this because
i don't i don't
necessarily see this idea of the
afterlife the way that
like like the modern kind of way of
understanding it um
let me think about that let me think
about how i would describe the afterlife
to a materialist
all right so cabal for five dollars
asked can you elaborate on
marrying the foreigner specifically as
it pertains to a man marrying a female
foreigner thank you
well yeah in scripture you have the
sense
that if you marry
the a foreigner then you are moving away
from your
self right you're you're bringing in
outside influence and that you know
in uh in in proverbs
especially solomon warns against that
like warns against
marrying the foreign woman the strange
woman he talks about
because then the fruit he talked about
then the fruit of your labor will go to
the foreign right
you can understand it it's like you take
something you marry
someone from the outside but their
attachment
is also too is still to the outside and
so
that which you hurt your children with
her and also your
your for the fruit of your work is going
to tend to move
out towards the outside and so
so that can be extremely dangerous
to to to your integrity uh but there are
also places in scripture where it it can
be also seen
as the the very capacity to move
into the outside right and so for
example
when christ marries
the the um
samaritan woman though there's a scene
in and when christ meets the samaritan
woman at
the well there's a mystical marriage
that happens
in his relationship with him it's hard
to explain here but
the the whole trope of the scene
is related to how the patriarchs found
their wives at the well
and then christ off talks about
quotes almost the text in proverbs which
talks about
the foreign woman because it in the the
text that talks about the foreign woman
solomon says keep your fountain
to to yourself don't let your fountain
run into the streets right so he's
talking about the problem of
letting your water go out into the
streets so that it's
so that it's diluted that it gets
muddied or you know it goes out and you
lose
the purity of your water right and so he
uses that specific image
to talk about not the reason why not to
marry the
the foreign woman but then christ says
i will give you a fountain that will
spring into eternity
and so christ is is actually marrying
the foreign woman in that that story
it's really crazy
like to realize that's what he's doing
but he's saying i can
i have a way to make you
participate without
me losing my the
value of my water right that it will
spring into eternity
um and so that's the meaning of mayor of
marrying the foreigner it has both a
positive
and a negative and it can still today
still be positive and negative
it's not uh not a one-way street in
terms of that
in terms of that uh that question
all right so lessons for life for six
six six
pounds says uh
i heard a nation of islam leader claim
the devil
equals devalue
is there any truth in this and is the
television
tell lies vision no
no do not listen to the nation of islam
leaders
just don't they they they are
not serious very not serious and so
sorry if if they're a nation of islam
i'm sure there are no national islam
people who follow my
channel but
these two the these devil
is and value and the value
devalue or whatever it's just not
they're just not the same roots they're
just not the same languages
you can't can't just make up
relationships of
language like that it just it's not
helpful
um tell lies vision
sorry man no that's when symbolism goes
off
goes off the goes off the hinges in my
opinion
all right so so david furtado for
5brl i know what drl is all right so
what is the difference between marriage
and the bible compared to marriage today
what exactly is the meaning of sex
outside of marriage
man you guys are you guys are bringing
me into troubled waters
the marriage in the bible is basically
you taking a wife that
taking a woman that does not belong to
someone else
that's what marriage is in the old
testament it is
a it is a taking of a woman who doesn't
belong to someone else
and having a kind of
covenant with her right there's a
promise
there's like a promise that i will take
care of you um
and so that's really what what marriage
is now
marriage today in terms of
the christian marriage has a far more
sacramental reality and it the marriage
is seen as a manner in which to
enact or to live out an
aspect of the truth of god um
and so it's very different
and so so that's why in christianity we
have the idea
that that you know you shouldn't have
sex outside of marriage um in the
old testament you didn't really have
that idea it's just not there
you know there's a
there's a crazy proverb that says
something like uh
where it says you know why would you go
we talked about the strange woman it
says why would you go to the strange
woman like why would you go to the
strange woman when the prostitute costs
so much you know it's like it just
wasn't it wasn't the same
the same vision right whereas in
christianity that would be completely
unacceptable right because we view
we really do view the relationship and
the wedding relationship as
as a manifestation of the mystery of god
and the soul the mystery of christ in
the church and so it's a way to enact
the pattern
at the different levels and we we
believe that it is the way in which
you will be transformed more fully if
you
live within that union like a
that you live a a form of
promise within that union you know um
whereas in the old testament
it was it was this is people are going
to stone me for saying this stuff but
it's just that what was there
the old testament it was the it was the
wife who was not
allowed to you know
be with another man it it doesn't seem
to go both ways like it just doesn't
seem to go both ways in the old
testament but
the new testament and in christianity
definitely does
it definitely does um
all right okay so sad
dab sav all right great name there my
friend
so for ten dollars uh on order in chaos
zeus justly exiled
mamas from mount olympus after much
haranguing symbolism happens well all
right
so chancellor turner for two dollars
says have you read niji
if so any thoughts i have read michi um
and uh it would be too complicated to
get into that here
maybe one day i can do that but i don't
think i'm gonna get into nietzsche too
much i mean i think nietzsche is a
is what he is he said what he said he
was he understood
the symbolism of he understood
what the symbolism of the modern world
was
and he embodied it like he of all people
he
understood what materialism meant he
understood
what it led to you know
and he he lived it out
to his own madness i have to say sadly
so
sadly whatever jimmy d thing all right
i'm out of control here
jimmy d thing uh for five dollars says
len so easter passover and ramadan all
took place during the quarantine this
year
that doesn't seem like a coincidence to
me is it providence i would say that it
should be
like i think that hopefully people took
it as
providential no matter what the
intentions or no matter what
other things are at play within uh this
quarantine
but um hopefully people took it as a
time
to renew in prayer and to um
and to understand what's truly important
you know
hopefully that's what happened all right
so brad's pit for 20 dollars
brad's pit is always there um
what are your thoughts on flips without
repentance god eg soviet union
restricting divorce
abortion under stalin is that the spirit
of antichrist we talked about in another
video a moral order from experience not
god
um
i mean the thing about
the thing about let's say
something like the soviet union there
were things in the soviet union which
were not
bad you know and so it's like so if you
restrict
divorce and abortion then
you know that was like is maybe an
excess of order
and a desire for society to function
well uh
and so it might have been motivated for
for bad reasons
you know but the the problem of
like yeah so a good a good i think
you've got it right in your thing which
is
the problem of moral orders we talked
about this like the problem of ethics
is is the delusion that
that's enough like the delusion that if
we have an ordered society that if we
can find the rules that order society
that that will be enough to preserve us
but it's not
it isn't ethics are not sufficient
morality is not enough for the world to
exist
morality has to be pointed up towards
something more so
so yeah yeah i feel like i'm getting it
myself
i don't know i feel like i'm getting
into trouble in this q a for some reason
all right i think this is gonna be the
last one guys it's 11. i can't believe i
went for two hours
usually i can't deal with two hours so
this is gonna be the last one all right
so
shot in the dark 90 for 20
says you said that the revolutions
devour themselves
it's a nation whose identity and origin
is wrapped up in revolution destined to
destroy itself
according to this pattern this perpetual
society is a
social decay a feature rather than a bug
i think so i think that uh that nations
based on
revolution are going to destroy
themselves that's for sure
um according yeah i think so
now it's perpetual social decay a
feature rather than a bug
um i would say that it is to a certain
extent
i think that if the pattern of the
pattern of decay is one which
is always gonna it's always there it's
not going away
um you know the idea is
how can we minimize the
the how can we minimize the the the
excess of the pattern right how can we
avoid
the really high highs and the really low
lows right how can we avoid things
breaking down completely
so you know you see you see that the
totalitarian states
in the 20th century just just
completely fell apart you know without
much of a residue and so
yeah there's not that's the idea is to
avoid that to find the balance between
unity and multiplicity
find the balance between order and
freedom or order and
forgiveness or you know from you know a
kind of
malleability in order to to to
prevent the major breakdowns but
it's a feature of the story it's not
it's there you know
the the idea that things are going to
get worse and then there's going to be
an
end and then there's going to be is
there in the story it's there in the
bible
and it's there in other cultures as well
so it seems to be
it seems to be it's not going to be
going away
all right everybody so
man i think this is the longest q a that
i've ever done
can't believe it so hopefully i haven't
alienated anybody beyond belief in this
in this last q a
i'll have to listen to it tomorrow um
and i appreciate everybody
i appreciate you guys being there and i
um
everybody who's been supporting me in
the last few months i've just been
astounded
and uh just so grateful that people
despite the chaos despite the madness
that people
despite that still want to to support
what i'm doing so i
want to say thanks i want to say thanks
to all the moderators
who are there and who are going through
all the insanity of the chat
and i know that that sometimes they
can't even
they can't even follow discussion
because it gets too crazy
and i know that some people like lisa
for example
is getting up at like three in the
morning to be a moderator on this so i
appreciate that
and brad heisman who who is
for the first time a moderator but who's
been a moderate on the facebook group
for a long time
so thanks everybody and i will see you
again
next month bye